now the German government is launching a
range of measures to attract skilled
workers from abroad in other news it
aims to combat the growing worker
shortage in the country it has hoped
that the points-based system will fill
around 2 million vacancies across
multiple industries from nursing to I.T
to public administration but the
proposals are being criticized by the
opposition for ignoring the potential of
skilled workers already in Germany
Sonia alagaband fled Iran to come to
Germany now she's fulfilling her dream
learning to become a train driver with
Germany's national Railway company
Deutsche Bahn
I didn't think that I could do something
like this here not at all I'm happy that
soon I'll be able to drive on my own
can
for Deutsche Bahn Sonja is a godsend the
company is desperately trying to fill
vacancies as they deal with a worker
shortage it's a nationwide problem
around 2 million workers are needed
across multiple industries from nursing
I.T daycare centers skilled trades and
public administration
the government hopes the key issues
paper they've adopted will help to solve
the shortage
we won't make any Headway in terms of
economic policy without more skilled
workers that means we are compelled to
act quickly and decisively
in addition to this Challenge and the
many crisis that we have to overcome
there are three major processes of
changing the economy they all start with
a D
digitalization decarbonization and
demographic change were addressed in the
latter with its key issues paper and a
degree of determination never seen
before in Germany
The Proposal its own version of a green
card to attract people from outside the
EU to Germany it would have a point
space system similar to the Canadian one
the criteria for a job offer could
include qualifications language skills
work experience connection to Germany
and age
but the idea is not without criticism
the opposition is arguing that the
potential of skilled workers already in
Germany should be exhausted first but
the ruling Coalition disagrees will pull
out all stops to raise the potential at
home so that a shortage of skilled
workers does not become a break on
growth and when we've done with all of
that it won't be enough we need
supplementary qualified immigration from
abroad
the aim is to allow 400 000 people to
immigrate every year quickly digitally
and unbureaucratically a draft bill will
be presented to the bundestag at the
beginning of next year
and from war now let's bring in DW
political correspondent Julia Sao Delhi
so we're hearing there the German
government appearing to have some
decisive measures in mind why now
well the three parties that are in the
uh coalition government at the moment
had already agreed on wanting to reform
Germany's migration laws already last
year when they signed a coalition
agreement but it's becoming ever clear
that Germany really is an urgent need of
more foreign workers if we look at the
numbers one in two companies in Germany
are suffering from a lack of skilled
workers in all kinds of sectors from
services to I.T manufacturing to health
care and the situation is expected to
get even worse if and no measures are
taken because of Germany's aging
population more people going into
retirement and the low birth rate that's
why we've seen the proposal of this
points-based system to allow foreign
workers outside of the EU to come to
Germany if they respect certain criteria
which depends on qualifications and
degrees work experience experience a
language skills skills and age and that
is meant to make the process easier for
skilled workers from abroad to come to
Germany but also to expand the pool of
qualified workers who can come and work
in Germany
and there are other pro-immigration
measures in the pipeline what's on the
table
yes so on the one hand the the Coalition
has put forward a work in progress is a
draft to make naturalization easier for
people who are already living in Germany
the process would be shortened from
eight to five years people would then be
able to apply for citizenship after five
years of living in Germany and it would
also allow a dual citizenship with
countries outside the EU and Switzerland
this is something that is not allowed
currently and that would for example in
particular impact the the big community
in in Germany with Turkish Roots who
have until now had to decide between a
Turkish and a German passport but their
planned reforms also look at the Asylum
process which the current government
wants to accelerate make faster less
bureaucratic and and more efficient and
it also looks at this
category of people that are under
so-called tolerated status that means
these are people whose Asylum claim has
been rejected but these people have not
been deported because of humanitarian or
technical reasons and now these people
if they've been in Germany for at least
five years would now receive a residence
permit on a one-year probation and that
is aimed to acknowledge the fact that
these people have built a life in
Germany in the last five years and that
they have a chance to to continue to
live in Germany and to stay here Julia
saudeli in Berlin thank you